just describe a little bit what was the
intent of the report well to your point
we look at oil and gas industry
practices and fracking itself really
isn't the issue but it's a related
practice of injecting wastewater deep
underground so when you produce oil and
gas whether you're talking about a
conventional well or a well that's been
fracked you also happen to produce a lot
of water in addition to the oil and gas
and we're talking about large volumes
here sometimes you get ten times more
water than you do oil and gas out of a
particular well so the question is what
do you do with all of that water will
the practice of the industry in most
parts of the US has been the drill a
separate well and pump all of that water
underground and that injection of that
wastewater is what seems to be related
to the earthquakes Rob tell us the
geographic areas that are covered in the
report that's right well certainly
Oklahoma Texas those are hot spots right
now but it's really in areas where
you're looking at oil and gas activity
generally so in Oklahoma specifically
the regulators are looking at this
industry practice they are they are also
doing that in Texas and so we have you
know we have this new sort of activity
that's coming under the the potential
scope of regulator so in Oklahoma in
Texas you could technically start
withdrawing permits for wastewater
injection if the regulators ultimately
decide that there's an issue here and
there's mounting evidence there's new
academic studies their studies from
scientists at the US Geological Survey
that really make this connection Robin
just as showing fracking earthquakes in
Oklahoma water injections and number of
three plus magnitude earthquakes do
these earthquakes pose any danger to
inhabitants certainly there is potential
for damage when you look at Oklahoma
they've had 250 earthquakes
q1 of this year they had almost 500
earthquakes last year that were greater
than a three point o scale and you know
that that's enough to potentially cause
cause some harm and if you go back over
time there were almost no earthquakes in
the area so there really is a link
between where you see these wastewater
injection wells and where you're
experiencing some of the earthquakes and
a lot of cases were essentially
discovering fault that we didn't know
existed in the past what about
wastewater and contamination yeah so I
mean that's why the wastewater is
essentially being injected deep
underground you could alternative is
that you could ultimately move towards
more wastewater recycling but cleaning
up the water is an expensive practice so
in most parts of the country that's
simply just not the the path we're
taking right now but that's one
potential regulatory solution lawsuits
Rob lawsuits are out there we're seeing
those heat up you know none of the
lawsuits have been successful yet there
have been some that have settled out of
court but this is a potential liability
for some of the producers and some of
the folks who operate these wastewater
disposal wells we're certainly seeing
folks law you're up and you know this
this is the great story of our time you
know we've had the shale energy
revolution occurring here in the US and
so far it's it's really not fallen under
any significant regulatory clawback but
this is an issue that that we're seeing
heat heat up and that's why we're
following it from a sort of industry
company perspective Rob increased
seismic activity is that necessarily a
bad thing well its energy is always
about trade-offs so you know I think III
don't think you're gonna find anyone
who's sort of going to be pro earthquake
but you know we have a lot of resource
in the ground
and you know maybe small tremors might
be acceptable that might be the
trade-off we're willing to make as a
society and again it's you know it's
openly not going to be my call it's
going to be the folks who are regulating
the industry in Oklahoma Texas who will
make that who do that calculus and I
wouldn't be surprised if we see
increased interest in the issue here in
Washington as well I mean this this is a
this is a big industry issue that's that
that will see playing out in the policy
space over the next few years and Rob
Barnett how can people get ahold of this
new report it's available on the
terminal for Bloomberg intelligence
customers all right one